neste momento um ano
eu não sei se todos já ouviram falar mas
que cruza vários fatores de
desenvolvimento é e que restitua you
neste gráfico está cruzado com a nossa
pegada ecológica e sua vez com mais
atenção ao olharem o gráfico que
acontece aqui muito claramente que
quanto maior é um desenvolvimento humano
também maior é nossa pegada ecológica e
no fundo esse é o primeiro desafio de um
novo que o desenvolvimento é conseguir
reduzir a pegada ecológica conseguir
também continuar a aumentar o índice de
desenvolvimento humano não das
populações na europa e estados unidos da
américa por nós chamamos o produz
projetos do mundo
mexia expulsões de áfrica e de lá e de
base é maioritariamente uma visão do
mundo em 2014 este é o cenário mauá
milhões pessoas que ainda têm fome
crônica a mil as pessoas que nos
alimenta o mundo ea mente como deve ser
mais uma vez nós somos é os banho
trilhos do mundo e em termos uma
influente uma escolha de conexão
a falta d'água também afeta muitos
milhões de pessoas em todo o mundo
claro que ele exonerou maria zona com
estresse hídrico maior mas um portugal
está inserido em portugal tem que olhar
para chuchu na fábrica de pranchas
cursinho da equipa à frente com uma com
uma visão diferente das coisas porque
também com as alterações climáticas
os três se detém em portugal que tenderá
a piorar e e escrita entre os finalistas
a universidade também não estamos bem
infelizmente nos últimos desde a década
de 70
houve uma perda de 30% da biodiversidade
ea de frustração tem aumentado e mesmo
nos países em desenvolvimento
na europa a nossa área de floresta
quase todas disse desanimada mas
centenas de anos e agora nós estamos a
tentar fazer é que os países em
desenvolvimento têm outro tipo de
movimento e não precisa acabar com as
suas florestas para darem boas condições
de vida às suas populações na energia é
meu partido ainda vai combustíveis
fósseis cerca de 80 porcento a nível
global mas também em portugal os números
são idênticos 80% da nossa energia hawai
do petróleo e do carvão e do gás natural
para tudo que vocês possam imaginar que
tem que consome no dia desde o carro
a electricidade a indústria a produção
do o transportam alimentos paa a
produção de bens tanto tudo isso consome
energia e 80% dessa energia vai dos
combustíveis fósseis
este é um gráfico que eu acho
interessante que um dia em que a
população mundial deixa de usar de forma
de gota a utilização sustentável dos
recursos naturais e na década de 70 e se
tinha era no 31 dezembro portanto na
década de 70 nós ainda éramos
sustentáveis
ainda estávamos a usar apenas os
recursos de um ano que é o planeta
conseguir repos mas cada vez estamos a
utilizar mostra executar os nossos
recursos naturais mais pressa tem 92 foi
a 21 de outubro em 2002 foi a 3 de
outubro 2012 já foi gostou de 22 e um
ano passado eu fui velocidade
o ano passado nós escutá los os bairros
que tentam espantar e que podem aula
próprio ar por 20 de agosto
tanto que estamos a florar mais
autorização e o consumo de recursos
naturais
as emissões de gases de efeito estufa e
as alterações climáticas
já 111 cientistas afirmarem que o maior
problema ambiental
o 21 por que postei consequências em
todos os outros problemas que podem ser
setoriais como o ordenamento do
território a exploração dos recursos
a utilização da água a ocupação do solo
etc
portanto este ipc fipe o ipc que é viver
painel intergovernamental de cientistas
com as alterações climáticas é um painel
de cientistas que trabalham de forma
voluntária para nações unidas tanto que
não trabalha na universidade mas todos
juntos todos para compilar os dados
sobre os dados disponíveis para analisar
o fenômeno das alterações climáticas
tanto este painel intergovernamental de
cientistas consideram que o aquecimento
global em equipe e é causado pela
atividade humana e que as temperaturas
globais podem aumentar cerca de 5 graus
celsius até 2100 portanto durante todo o
século 20 e 15 graus celsius o nível ao
nível é o google ao não parece muito mas
se olhamos também para o nosso país e as
aletas um camping o nosso umbigo em em
regiões como em tese em que as
temperaturas no verão já chegou a 45
graus celsius se firma dispusemos mais
três ou quatro podem vir gil no planeta
entre também portugal que vê que deixam
de poder ser habitáveis habitadas
importante parte das alterações
climáticas já nós quando a evitar mas a
outra parte que sim e alguma japão já
estamos a sofrer as suas consequências
como nos grandes furacões o gênero
chamado megan incêndios odiou no ártico
e também a certificação nos dar um
panorama sobre a crítica alterações
climáticas a nível ao nível mundial
tanto estas que esta questão está a ser
estudada há já vários anos
a e a onu estão phil stu painel
intergovernamental de cientistas para
para estudar este fenómeno das
alterações climáticas é conversão das
alterações climáticas também das nações
unidas 92
com o eco 92 depois os cientistas
continuarão a produzir relatórios tempos
a tempos não servir como base para as
decisões políticas
infelizmente eles nem sempre acontece e
isso deve acontecer mais vezes do que
acontece mas em 2000 em 1997 foi
assinado o protocolo de kyoto e teve
como objetivo diminuir as emissões
globais de efeito estufa em todo o mundo
este protocolo de kyoto tinha uma base
do sul e da unidade entre países
desenvolvidos e em desenvolvimento ou
seja os países deu é que os que já
emitiram há mais tempo gases com efeito
estufa cuja principal é o dióxido
carbono e os países vinham ser os
primeiros a reduzir as suas emissões e
por isso é que o protocolo de kyoto só
obriga os países em teor os países
desenvolvidos a baixar a reduzir as suas
emissões e por isso quando temos de ver
china não dá não está a fazer nada
a china é um país em desenvolvimento
para aumentar imenso as suas emissões já
emite mais que estados unidos da américa
as duas dividiram as emissões por porque
ela por cada cidadão per capita
chegamos à conclusão que um chinês a emi
trair 8 que o co2 por ano e um americano
para 25 1 europeu m
cerca de treze e nós andamos nos 10 um
africano mp os três portanto são mais ou
menos os valores per capta serão justiça
de emissões da população mundial entra
entre os países
copenhaga foi todos usam
os políticos os países reúnem para
discutir esta questão das alterações
climáticas e como é que vamos resolvê lo
é copa essas conferências chamas suas
conferências das partes
as partes são os países a copa reúne
todos os anos
aí eu não já agora tem várias cópias em
copo sobre a biodiversidade e esses
sobre alterações climáticas é mas é mais
falado que o momento foi a cop copenhaga
onde vendes e alguns países mais
proativos onde a união européia está
inserida criam que vencendo o corpo de
redução de gases de efeito estufa a
partir de 2020
isso não foi possível não chegou à
conclusão nenhuma em copenhague o que o
celular foi que cada país oficias por
dia o que queria
ora nós sabemos como não funciona assim
que as grandes mudanças necessárias não
é porque não oferece mash e se calhar
infelizmente porque não é obrigado a
fazer portanto este é não é muito
importante passe climática fato a oms
está a sair com um novo relatório e é o
que nós esperamos nós organizações não
governamentais de ambiente também
desenvolvimento esperamos que os
políticos olhem para ir para estes novos
dados e que seja também um 'tour' bancar
de decisões a ter a cópia turístico fará
em 2015 onde esperamos que aí haja força
política e vontade política para que
tenhamos um caminho a decepção de
emissões de gases de efeito estufa de
frente que tivemos até aqui já ouviu
falar em foi um tema que a comunicação
social tudo muito foi neste quinto
relatório do ipc-s e que como como é
novo
querem interessante trazer cá a estas
estas conclusões tanto em setembro
vocês têm uma eleição me aos cientistas
a trabalharem todos juntos o que eles
fizeram foi vive nire o relatório por
temas
o primeiro relatório que é sobre esse
climática é avalia e analisa os dados de
temperatura o mna da subida do nível dos
oceanos e credos entra para traçar e
encaminho do como é que estes estão a
evoluir na o nível global e no nosso
planeta
portanto o que eu chegar a uma conclusão
é que os seres humanos que estão
responsáveis pela melhoria do
aquecimento global e também pelos seus
impactos e as emissões de gases de
efeito estufa que isso é uma coisa quem
é controversa em algumas partes do
planeta são de fato o principal a
causadora dando do aquecimento global
nos últimos 60 anos depois como eu disse
é chegar a uma conclusão que o aumento
da temperatura global poderá atingir 4
cerca de 100 graus celsius até 2100 é
como é que os fazem isso os cientistas
nós ouvimos mais falar ao nível ao nível
econômico e quando acabar
ouvimos mais falar o nível econômico
tanto assim os portugal vai crescer x
portugal aí vai aumentar o pib vai
diminuir o pib
cientistas fazem exatamente a mesma
coisa pega on line como a humanidade
pode incluir a população vai aumentar
muito se vamos produzir mais energia por
fontes renováveis nós vamos continuar
com os combustíveis fósseis
depois pegarem estudo fazem uma linha
tendência do aumento da saudade dos
gases de efeito estufa ou não tanto mais
impacto se muito provavelmente não
houver mais ondas de calor uma com grau
de incerteza
pesa muito grande é e os impactos
ambientais estão à flor ar portanto
depois já este ano é o ovo um relatório
que foi muito muito falado sobre os
impactos das alterações climáticas e
aqui a este método chama a atenção para
os impactos sul da europa têm a ver com
os incêndios florestais ainda irão
aumentar mais coisa e não das suas
costeiras também aumentar em mais e
também incluem pacotes econômicos por
exemplo província com o aumento da
temperatura no verão irá diminuir o
turismo e na zona onde portugal está em
10 o trem das montanhas e portanto quais
são os desafios do terceiro relatório o
prefeito os cientistas são muito claros
dizem que para atacar uma pessoa que
mata que precisa ver com precisão o
nível internacional mas também tem que
ver mais e mais com pressão o nível
local e regional
é preciso triplicar até 2050 a produção
de energia por fontes limpas optou por
fontes de zero emissões e as emissões
têm que ser reduzidas em 60 por cento
até 2050 portanto os cientistas são
muito claros estão a apontar caminhos
agora falta nós sabemos se iremos ouvir
o jornal
em portugal temos que aumentar a nossa
eficiência energética
temos que vocês tenham bissau mas é no
primeiro trimestre portugal que 90 por
cento da sua electricidade de fontes
renováveis o que põe assim no top 3 da
união européia aee a utilização de
energias renováveis e pois é um problema
muito grave que precisa atacar em
portugal que é o ordenamento do
território
utilizamos demasiado nosso transporte
individual e isso é terrível para as
nossas emissões nos sistemas
o nosso consumo de energia em transporte
é tanto como o consumo da indústria
espera nós na nossa visão é um problema
tem que ser atacado
já para não para não piorar o que tu fim
deixamos essa mensagem para estudos
impossível é preciso aumentar
an é preciso aumentar a sensibilização
dos pilares civil onde os jovens têm um
papel fundamental é que costumam ser
mais otimistas quanto ao futuro do que
as gerações mais velhas a e portanto é
preciso e yero que tem tentado fazer
este papel e tenho tentado ajudar na
sensibilização sobre alterações
climáticas ea gestão algumas das duas
ações que temos realizado e pronto era
isso que eu tenho como dizer muito
obrigado a nossa atenção